nous vivons les derniers jours de paix
ce qui devait être un jour ordinaire
se révéla extraordinaire
cet appareil est mis dans les pattes
arrière d une attaque furtive d'une
redoutable puissance
déstabiliser un pays et bouleversa le
monde nous devons mener une attaque
contre les équipements nucléaires de la
place de juan san
nous n'avons pas le choix si on ne fait
rien le nord pourrait déployer ce
missile nucléaire
nous n'enverrons qu'une seule troupe
d'élite le succès de cette mission
repose sur votre capacité à unir vos
forces
vous êtes les meilleurs pilotes de
l'armée de l'air
avec ma compagne ou visio
[Musique]
win fighters les guerriers du ciel